cali está en un día de campo con seis
amigos el mayor de sus amigos es vikram
y tiene diez años de edad la menor es
villa y tiene seis años
cali tiene un total de 48 moras azules y
las quiere dividir entre sus amigos en
partes iguales cuantas moras azules le
tocan a cada uno de sus amigos y los
invito a qué pausa en el vídeo y traten
de resolver esto por ustedes mismos
cuantas moras azules le tocan a cada uno
de sus amigos
vamos a pensar un poco en esto ella
tiene seis amigos y quiere que cada uno
de ellos tenga el mismo número de moras
azules quiere dividir sus 48 moras
azules en partes iguales entre sus
amigos las edades de sus amigos no son
importantes así que ella toma las 48
moras azules y las divide entre 6 tiene
6 amigos y las quiere dividir en seis
grupos 48 entre 6
entonces el signo de interrogación es
igual al número de moras azules que cada
uno de los amigos va a tener entonces 48
entre 6 igual a signo de interrogación
es lo mismo que decir que 48 es igual a
signo de interrogación
por 6 tenemos que encontrar el número
que multiplicado por 6 sea igual a 48 el
signo de interrogación es igual al
número de moras azules por cada amigo
multiplicado por 6 amigos es igual al
número total de moras azules que es 48
así que cuál es este número vamos a
pensar un poco en los múltiplos de 66
por 1 es igual a 66 por 2 es igual a 12
estoy incrementando de 6 en 6 sumando 6
cada vez
6 por 3 es igual a 18 6 por 4 es igual a
24 6 por 5 es igual a 36 por 6 es igual
a 36 6 por 7 es 42 observen que estoy
sumando 6 cada vez 6 por 8 es igual a 48
ahora sabemos que el signo de
interrogación debe ser igual a 8 6 por 8
y 8 por 6 es lo mismo así que tenemos
que el signo de interrogación por 6 es
igual a 6 por signo de interrogación y
ahora sabemos que el signo de
interrogación es igual a 8
entonces cada uno de sus amigos va a
tener 8 moras azules y aquí escribimos
que 48 moras azules divididas entre 6
amigos es igual a 8 moras azules ahora
vamos a verificar esto aquí tenemos 48
moras azules y las vamos a dividir entre
6 grupos cada grupo va a tener 8 moras
azules voy a tratar de hacer lo mejor
que pueda
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 aquí está el primer
grupo de 8 moras azules aquí tenemos el
segundo grupo de moras azules 8 moras
azules más aquí tengo otro grupo justo
aquí otro grupo de 8 moras azules
aquí tengo el cuarto grupo de 8 moras
azules
de este lado tengo el quinto grupo de
ocho monos azules
y por último aquí está el sexto grupo de
ocho moras azules
observen que tenemos seis grupos de ocho
moras azules y cada uno de los amigos de
cali puede tomar uno de estos grupos de
ocho moras azules